all of our Studios professional products
support proxy authentication today we'll
look at an example specifically for
shining server pro but the process is
similar for both our studio konnekt in
our studio server Pro as well before
looking at proxy authentication is
important to understand the regular
authentication workflow the first step
is that a user will request a piece of
content if that content is restricted or
requires authentication shiny server Pro
will respond to the client asking for
the users credentials typically a
username and password once the
credentials are received shiny server
Pro will check to make sure that the
credentials are in fact correct and it
will do so by looking against either a
flat file database or one of the
authentication services specified in the
Chinese server Pro configuration file
for example the auth LDAP directive or
the auth ad directive if the username
and password supplied by the user
matches up with those on file
shiny server Pro will then proceed to
check whether or not the user has access
to a specific piece of content specified
in the shiny server Pro configuration
file as the required user or required
group directive if indeed the user has
access Chinese server Pro will serve the
content and note that the username is
available to the application developer
in the session dollar sign user object
again there are two primary steps the
first is the user proving that they are
who they say they are
and the second is determining which
content the user has access to you and
then serving that content in proxy
authentication we have the same workflow
that steps to in step 3 our outsource to
a proxy server specifically a user will
request a piece of shiny content and
that request will be routed through the
proxy server the proxy server will then
communicate with the user to ID who they
are and to confirm that they are who
they say they are and this process if
they're already logged in can be done
biasing
sign-on without direct involvement from
the user once the proxy server has
authenticated the user it'll pass
the user information to shiny server Pro
through a secure HTTP header that
contains a key value pair the key can be
specified inside of the shining server
Pro configuration file shiny silver Pro
will then accept that the user is who
the proxy server has identified them to
be a note of caution the sure shiny
server will only accept incoming
requests from the proxy because shiny
server Pro accepts these requests as
truth if a user were to sign their own
HTTP header shiny server Pro would trust
them as well so all requests should go
to shiny server Pro through the proxy
then shiny server Pro after receiving
the authenticated user name proceeds as
before by checking whether the user has
access to a specific piece of content
and if they do serving that content
typically the proxy server can come in a
variety of different forms today we'll
look at a specific example using a tool
called OAuth 2 proxy which is an open
source piece of software that allows the
user to communicate with a variety of a
lot to providers specifically in this
case github if you are interested in the
details please take a look at the bitly
github page for OAuth 2 proxy which
describes the steps necessary to set up
this particular proxy server as well as
the OAuth 2 endpoints and specifically
today we'll be using github as our wot
tube provider inside of github under
settings you can specify an OAuth
application which is what we've done
here so I'm going to go and request a
piece of content from shiney server
right now I'm running Chinese server Pro
and the proxy both on localhost the
proxy is listening on port 80 shiny
server Pro is listening on point port 38
38 so I'm going to go through the proxy
by requesting the
content just at port 80 or localhost
let's see that the proxy to proxy is
asking me to sign in with my github
account so I'll proceed to do so
and after signing in the github has
authenticated me past that
authentication back to the oauth2 proxy
server which has then forwarded my
username to shiny silver Pro you can see
that shiny server Pro is now aware of
Who I am logged in as Sean if I were to
do this again so to open up a new window
and to again request and shiny server
pro via the proxy server you'll see that
this time I am directed directly to
shiny server because the browser has
cached the authentication cookies so it
knows who I am and therefore single
sign-on is achieved because I don't have
to directly involve myself in the
authentication process we still walk
through the proxy server communicating
with a github client and then passing
along the HTTP header the shiny server
pro but all of that is done on my behalf
by the browser hopefully this gives you
a good starting point for setting up
your own proxy server and successfully
authenticating users thank you